es wird noch viel schlimmer sagt die
nasa und das ist hier nicht nur so
anspruch die bevölkerung an den küsten
weltweit ist deutlich stärker gefährdet
als bisher vermutet was nämlich den
anstieg des meeresspiegels angeht wurde
ein kleines aber leider entscheidendes
detail vergessen das wackeln des mondes
könnte ab mitte der 2030er jahre für
schwere überschwemmungen sorgen so die
amerikanische raumfahrtbehörde
warum das feiern des mondes plötzlich
das leben auf der erde gefährden könnte
und was wir dagegen tun sollten all das
gibt es jetzt hier bei klicks um salz in
future gibt es dreimal pro woche
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktive die glocke nur so
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen
sie eiert die umlaufbahn des mondes
dieses phänomen ist schon seit fast 300
jahren bekannt und eigentlich stellt es
für das leben auf der erde keine große
gefahr dar es handelt sich um einen
astronomischen effekt des mondzyklus und
fachleute sprechen von der sogenannten
libration manchmal auch vom trommeln
oder pendeln des mondes zustande kommt
dass durch seine ellipsen bahn in einem
zyklus von
18,6 jahren ändert sich die position des
mondes relativ zur erde und das hat
natürlich auswirkungen auf die gezeigten
wie gesagt eigentlich kein grund zur
beunruhigung doch hinzu kommt ab dem
jahr 2030 wohl ein weiterer faktor und
in kombination mit dem mondzyklus könnte
das der amerikanischen raumfahrtbehörde
nasa zufolge verheerende folgen haben
eine echte schock prognose also die die
nasa jetzt in einer aktuellen studie
heraus gibt demnach könnte es bereits in
wenigen jahren ab dem jahr 2030 enormen
flutalarm an den küsten weltweit geben
und strothmann also noch stärkere und
häufigere überschwemmungen als die die
ohnehin jetzt schon passieren was genau
dahinter steckt das kennen wir jetzt
hier per klick zum science and future
ganze 400.000 kilometer ist unser mond
von der erde entfernt und trotzdem hat
der riesigen einfluss auf unseren
planeten mit seiner anziehungskraft
bewirkt er evo und flut doch er hat noch
weitere auswirkungen und die sind für
das leben auf der erde entscheiden zb
stabilisiert unser mond seit mehr als
vier milliarden jahren das klima auf der
erde durch seine schwerkraft wird die
erdachse beruhigt ohne ihn würde sie
deutlich stärker schwanken zudem würde
sich die erde ohne den mond wohl
schneller drehen die tage werden also
kürzer denn seine schwerkraft bremste ab
manche wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler gehen davon aus dass
unser mond die existenz von leben auf
der erde erst möglich gemacht hat denn
der mond sorgt seit vier milliarden
jahren für relativ stabile
wetterbedingungen auf der erde und da
die natur stabile bedingungen bevorzugt
könnte das dafür gesorgt haben dass
leben überhaupt erst auf der erde
entstehen konnte so die vermutung
mancher fachleute davon geht auch der
us-wissenschaftler steven kane aus er
hat vor allem sogenannte gezeigten
tümpel im visier gemeint sind damit
pfützen oder tümpel an küsten die
während der flut mit wasser versorgt
sind bei ebbe aber keine verbindung zu
mehr haben dazu sagt in gezeigten
tümpeln können sehr hohe konzentrationen
von nährstoffen auftreten und so
potenziell dazu beitragen dass sich
leben entwickelt der astronomen sucht
auf planeten außerhalb unseres
sonnensystems nach außerirdischem leben
und hat sich dabei auf planeten mit
monden spezialisiert doch der mond hat
nicht nur positive effekte auf das leben
auf der erde davor warnt jetzt die nasa
demnach könnte bereits in wenigen jahren
die überschwemmungsgefahr in küstennahen
städten deutlich steigen dazu sagt der
nasa mitarbeiter brille nelson
tiefliegende gebiete sind zunehmend
gefährdet und leiden unter den
zunehmenden überschwemmungen und es wird
nun noch schlimmer werden die
kombination aus der anziehungskraft des
mondes dem steigenden meeresspiegel und
dem klimawandel wird die überschwemmung
an unseren küsten und auf der ganzen
welt weiter verschlimmern
in der studie hat sich ein nasa
forschungsteam erstmals alle
astronomischen und ozeanischen ursachen
genauer angesehen so kamen die
forschenden zu der erkenntnis dass in
der nahen zukunft zwei faktoren
zusammenkommen werden die tragisch für
die bevölkerung an den küsten sind zum
einen das wackeln oder eiern des mondes
in der ersten hälfte des mondzyklus der
insgesamt 18,6 jahre dauert werden die
täglichen gezeigten abgeschwächt die
flut ist da niedriger als sonst und die
apple höher als normal in der zweiten
hälfte dagegen werden die gezeigten
verstärkt heißt also im klartext die
flut wird höher und die apple niedriger
als sonst was hinzu kommt der steigende
meeresspiegel bedingt durch den
menschengemachten klimawandel durch die
globale erwärmung schmilzt das
gletschereis in die ozeane allein in
grönland und der antarktis schmelzen
jedes jahr 400 milliarden tonnen eis
fachleute sind sich nicht ganz einig wie
hoch der meeresspiegel in den kommenden
jahren steigen wird manche prognose geht
davon aus dass er bis zur mitte des
jahrhunderts wohl auf jeden fall um die
20 bis 30 zentimeter ansteigen wird wie
es dann weitergeht ist noch unklar in
niedrig geschätzten szenarien gehen
fachleute davon aus dass es bis zum ende
des jahrhunderts einen globalen
meeresspiegelanstieg von 30 bis 60
zentimetern geben könnte pessimistische
szenarien befürchten da an
meeresspiegelanstieg zwischen 60
zentimeter und einem meter und das in
kombination mit dem mondzyklus könnte
fatale werden so dass naser
forschungsteam dabei sieht man die
tragischen bilder immer wieder im netz
oder fernsehen heftige überschwemmungen
machen den menschen in den küstennahen
städten der usa schon jetzt das leben
schwer in den vergangenen zwei jahren
seit 2009 10 hat die us wetter und
ozeanografiebehörde national oceanic and
atmospheric administration noaa mehr als
600 gezeigten fluten gemeldet doch schon
bald könnten die fluten in
küstengegenden nicht nur häufiger
vorkommen sondern auch noch dramatischer
ausfallen das forschungsteam warnt in
der aktuellen studie davor dass die flut
in zukunft nicht nur höher werden wird
sondern teilweise sogar einen monat oder
sogar noch länger andauern könnte die
anzahl der überschwemmungs tage könnte
dann im vergleich zu heute um drei bis
viermal höher liegen der verstärkte
zyklus des mond wackens ist für mitte
der 2030er jahre vorher gesagt dann wird
auch der meeresspiegel weiter gestiegen
sein bedingt durch den klimawandel gegen
dem wir derzeit nicht aktiv wirklich
angehen die fluten werden dann dort nasa
studien die meeresküsten der usa hawaii
und guam noch stärker als bisher
überschwemmt klimaphänomene wie
beispielsweise el niño könnten diesen
effekt sogar noch weiter verstärken die
küsten im äußersten norden der usa und
alaskas könnten erst mal einige jahre
verschont bleiben so das forschungsteam
denn dort steigen die landflächen an und
zwar aufgrund langfristiger geologische
prozesse die nasa forscher sind sich
also sicher dass die beiden faktoren
mond und klimawandel schon bald
sichtbare folgen für das leben auf der
erde haben werden der hauptautor der
studie viel thompson warnt davor dass
die lage ernst genommen werden muss das
sei bislang nicht der fall
überschwemmungen die durch die flut
ausgelöst werden seien demnach in den
köpfen der menschheit keine wirkliche
gefahr doch damit ist seiner meinung
nach nicht zu spaßen zitat aber wenn es
zehn oder fünfzehn mal im monat eine
flut gibt kann ein geschäft dessen
parkplatz unter wasser steht nicht
arbeiten menschen verlieren ihre
arbeitsstelle weil sie nicht zur arbeit
gelangen und sickergruben werden zu
einem problem der öffentlichen
gesundheit weitere mögliche folgen
küstenstädte werden überflutet
trinkwasser wird vernichtet und
ackerland wird unbrauchbar
die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler wollen jetzt ihre daten
veröffentlichen
die politik soll damit zum handeln
gebracht werden bereits jetzt müsse man
sich auf den drohenden fluten
vorbereiten so die nasa dazu seien
solche informationen wie sie die
aktuelle studie liefert dringend
notwendig wenn man weiß dass alle
ereignisse in einem monat liegen und
dass man im zweiten halbjahr schlimmere
überflutungen haben wird als im ersten
halbjahr das sind wertvolle
informationen auch küstennahe städte in
und um europa könnten dann betroffen
sein denn das eis in der antarktis wird
immer weniger und der meeresspiegel
steigt immer mehr so auch an der nordsee
der klima experte dirk notz vom max
planck institut für meteorologie
empfiehlt in einem interview mit dem
deutschlandfunk bereits jetzt
vorzusorgen neue deiche müssen jetzt
bereits einen meter höher gebaut werden
zudem müsse man einplanen dass man bis
ende des jahrhunderts möglicherweise
noch einen meter drauf setzen muss klar
ist den mondzyklus haben wir nicht in
der hand und das wackeln des mondes gibt
es schon seit einigen milliarden jahren
an sich ein ungefährliches phänomen doch
in kombination mit dem anstieg des
meeresspiegels kommt es wohl schon bald
zur komplikation noch ein grund mehr die
klimakrise schnell und wirksam zu
bekämpfen der klimaforscher der klotz
hat es im dlf interview auf den punkt
gebracht wir haben es nach wie vor in
der hand wie stark dieser globale
klimawandel ausfallen wird wie viel eis
wir verlieren aber halt auch wie stark
die extremereignisse in zukunft sein
werden da sind wir wirklich durch unser
aller handeln
diejenigen die das nach wie vor in der
hand haben und an dieser stelle verlinkt
ich immer ein video und mit diesem hier
der link ist schon mal hier und hat es
etwas ganz besonderes auf sich es
entspricht nämlich absolut den youtube
richtlinien trotzdem hat es youtube
offenbar in den suchergebnissen und
empfehlungen so gut wie nicht gezeigt
und sieht man sich die ergebnisseite zum
thema klimawandel auf youtube an dann
sieht das extrem mysteriös aus nahezu
ausschließlich videos von großen sendern
und medienhäusern sind hier zu sehen so
sieht normalerweise eine
suchergebnisseite aus mit vielen
verschiedenen kanälen von vor allem
unabhängigen kanälen und so sieht sie
beim thema klimawandel aus und das ist
auch so bei anderen themen feminismus
hier zum beispiel youtube unterdrückt
ganz bewusst videos von unabhängigen
kanälen demnächst gibt's hier mehr dazu
mit dem verein fair tube haben wir
gerade dazu eine aktion gestartet ich
war bei den spurs fox zu gast der link
ist auch hier unter mir und er hier
könnt ihr euch mehr zur aktion stil
youtube informieren und auch mitmachen
so und hier geht es jetzt zum von
youtube versteckten video also anklicken
anschauen und abonnieren und vor allem
weiterempfehlen demnächst hier mehr zur
aktion will youtube bis dann bleibt dran